all right and we have our linkedin live
audience with us today our youtube live
audience and of course
people participating in the live webex
event
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn welcome
to our cloud computing master class
yeah
let me
bring that up
our lecturer today is persia tomo
asadani dr astani is an assistant
professor
um at srcem
i'll introduce him a little bit
in a moment but first i want to let the
people on webex know
that you can enter questions for him in
the q a panel at any time and we'll
queue those up to take it the q a
section of the webinar toward the end
you can also put information in chat
i'll be taking a look at that as he's
talking so
i also wanted to let you know that we'll
be doing a few polls if you're watching
on our live stream you can respond to
the polls or
putting questions into your
comment section and we have people
watching that as well so
let me
launch this first poll which is pretty
straightforward just to give
push some uh idea of
the level of experience in our audience
today and also
a check-in question to see how you're
doing
as we've been going through the
ups and downs of the pandemic for the
last couple of years we've been asking
folks
give us a little bit of a check-in
give you another 20 seconds here
i'm hearing a siren in the background
outside my
office but uh
hopefully you didn't hear that um
here we go
so the first time we have an experienced
audience with us today half the audience
has uh
five or more years of experience um
and did pretty even distribution among
the
less experienced crowd
um
also it's good to see that
almost everybody is checking in
doing well or doing okay
hopefully what you get right here yeah
hopefully what you have to share with
the audience will improve the uh outlook
of the other you percent
so um again
uh
professor asadani
at sri rama uh um
college
of engineering and management he is a
specialist in cloud computing operating
systems
and has been named google scholar so
we're
very fortunate to have him on our
faculty and
with that i'm going to
stop sharing my screen
and allow him to share his
one moment
and you should be
all set to go
yes
thank you thanks a lot stuart i'll just
share my screen and
i will
just yep and let's just stop the video
yeah and i'll just start my video i hope
i am visible as well
yes thanks a lot stuart
yes so uh
yes guys just give me a moment just a
second
yeah
yes so welcome everyone hello everyone
welcome to simply learn
i am pursuit i'm dr pursuit masudani
assistant professor at sri ramdev
college of engineering and management
nagpur
and thank you stuart for my introduction
so guys how are you doing today i hope
all are doing well
so a very warm welcome to all of you and
good evening to all and good morning to
all others who are in different time
zones as well
right
so
i welcome all of you here
yes so let me tell you
what is going to be the topic of our
discussion for the day
so i'll just put in the agenda here
and then we'll get started
right
and as to it as rightly told you if you
have any queries you can put it in the
chat window
right
and yeah
yes and uh
in between the topic or at the end of
the topic i'll try to answer your
queries right guys
so feel free to put in your queries and
i'll be happy to answer those thank you
okay so let's begin
yes so today's agenda is we will see how
we can deploy our website on azure web
apps using devops practices with our
deployment slots and this is something
that we are going to achieve with a
service in azure that is called as web
apps okay
so let me start the discussion on azure
web apps
correct so what is basically a web app
so guys web app is nothing but a
platform as a service component in azure
okay
yeah just give me a second
yes
so let me put it here what do you
understand by a web app guys so i'll
just put in here
right and we'll get in
right so
so guys web apps are one of the one of
the most widely used
azure service
that enables us to host our web
applications in azure
it can host a user interactive
application or even a backend service
like say a wcs service or web apis right
so that's what a web app can do for us
right then um with web apps
what we can do is
with web apps
uh
sorry this is repetitive
just a second
yeah so with web apps
uh
so sorry this is coming again
so with web apps guys we can leverage
the power of microsoft azure and we can
build a multi
functional immensely scalable
highly secured and seamlessly accessible
internet or internet based applications
okay
now what you need to do with web app is
we need to just push our application
package into something called as a web
app and then the azure app service will
take care of anything and everything
that is required to keep our application
running so basically web apps is offered
to you as a platform as a service
component guys that is it is offered to
you
as a pass service right so
uh what you have to do is you just have
to put your application in
the azure web app your web app your
application and then azure web app will
take care of everything in anything and
everything that is required to keep your
application up and running that is it
will take care of the infrastructure
that is required to keep your
application running behind the scenes
okay so that is what a web app will do
for you okay then i would like to put in
here that the most important advantage
of using a web application is that we
did not have to worry about the
infrastructure plumbing that may be
required to host our application okay
because as i told you it's a pass
service so you don't have to worry about
the infrastructure plumbing the um
[Music]
managing your infrastructure would be
taken care of by the provider in this
case the microsoft right so that you
don't have to worry about with an azure
web app right guys so that's what i can
say now i'll just show you a diagram and
i'll try to
tell you something with this so see what
happens in case of a traditional web
hosting in case of the traditional web
hosting guys what used to happen is we
need to make sure that our server was up
and the os is updated and the iis was
running fine right on which your
application would be running
but in case of
a web app what happens is that there is
something called as this azure service
fabric now what is this azure service
fabric
so this is nothing but a layer um which
is also called as a magic layer which
which actually manages your
infrastructure okay which actually will
manage the server the os and the web
server is so this magical abstraction
piece that is azure service fabric will
uh make sure that you are being uh
given the appropriate resources right
that your web app is um having the uh
appropriate resources that the servers
is fine out there
i mean server is up os is updated and
iis is running right so this is taken
care of by this
service that is called as azure service
fabric which is nothing but also called
as a magical abstraction piece which
will take care of anything and
everything
um that is required uh for keeping your
web application running okay
so this actually also abstract these
internal resources that is the operating
system the um
physical server and the and the web
server iis these dependencies these uh
this apps this actually abstracts it
from you right so you don't have to
worry about all of these things and the
azure service fabric will take care of
anything and everything that is required
for uh
running your web application right
so that is being done by this azure
service fabric right guys
okay so
um fine so this is what an azure service
fabric will do for you right
right i hope this is clear to you yes so
if this is clear we'll just go and we
will see now the scenario on how we can
actually uh
use the web app right so
see here i've written also
that
this azure service fabric makes sure
that the web app is allocated with all
the required computing power
and the resources right so azure service
fabric runs
this magical abstraction piece okay
so this azure service fabric runs the
magical abstraction piece called as the
service fabric and this is the magic
that abstracts the server resources for
you and make sure that your server
whenever your server fails your
application keeps running on another
server right so this is being taken care
of by azure service fabric right
right so this is being taken care of by
azure service fabric
right guys
so that is there
fine
i hope this is clear to all of you guys
yeah
yeah
so yeah uh okay yeah sure i was just
trying to see if there are in questions
yes so now uh
now let me tell you the features of web
apps okay so the features of
the web app are that it supports auto
scaling that is if the load increases
you can increase the number of uh
instances behind your web apps uh and if
the load decreases you can decrease the
number of instances also let's say guys
with
let me take the example of
flipkart amazon so these shopping
websites right so the
load on these websites it's not the same
all around the year so during the sale
days the load on their websites
increases like anything so to cater to
such a load
the number of instances
on which your web app should be running
would be running on which the website
would be running should be increased and
when the load decreases those instances
should be terminated as well additional
instances right so when the load is up
so new instances should be created and
the when the load goes down so those
additional instances should go down as
well so this can be done in an auto
scale manner automatically with the help
of auto scale feature of web app right
so you can increase or decrease the
number of instances
as per your need
and you can increase them
when needed in an automated fashion
right so that like during the sale days
uh with the shopping websites like
flipkart amazon so the load increases so
new instances can be provisioned in an
automated fashion right to cater to that
additional load otherwise the website
performance may hamper or it may go down
uh the website right so this can be done
in an auto scaled manner and this is
possible with your azure web app right
guys so this is possible with your azure
web app so this is supported in azure
web app then it also supports easy
deployment that is it is possible to
integrate
your azure web app with the ci cd
pipeline of devops that is continuous
integration continuous deployment
pipeline of devops
then it also gives you language choice
so you can have your web app uh in
different languages guys that is also
possible then it also gives you security
so you can integrate your uh web app
with azure id and you can allow the
users in azure ready to either blacklist
or whitelist i mean i mean to allow
those users to use your web app and you
can also blacklist your whitelist some
ip or addresses in web apps so that now
you can decide that from which ip
address um there should be an access to
the web app and from which ip address
that should not be have an access to the
web app right then uh as far as the
diagnostics are concerned guys so there
are a lot of diagnostic related
information
that are available with your web apps
that helps you to that helps the
application to resolve any issues that
comes in your web app right so there are
a lot of diagnostic related settings
that are also available with your web
app
right guys so now if you are good with
this i'll just uh would like to uh share
a scenario here that is what we would
try to do in our lab right so i've just
given you a gist on web apps more on it
i'll explain you in the lab but that the
lab that we'll be doing is we will be
trying to implement this end-to-end
scenario in our lab okay guys so see now
you need to evaluate the use of azure
web apps i'll discuss this scenario out
for you the use case
so you need to evaluate the use of azure
web apps for hosting contoso source
websites so there is a company called as
contoso let's say we have taken any
company's name let's say contoso so
you need to evaluate the use of azure
web apps for hosting this company that
is contoso's website which is currently
being hosted in the companies on
premises data centers so contoso company
is currently using
the company's on-premises data center
okay
to host its web application but now
you have to make use of azure web apps
for the same so the websites are
currently running in on the windows
servers using php runtimes tech in its
on-premise is correct
now so when we will be using our web app
to host this company website so we will
also try to use windows servers with php
runtimes tech because
we have to
run the same
website on web apps now in azure right
so that is there
then
you also need to determine that how you
can implement the devops practices by
leveraging the azure web app deployment
slots so guys we will try to deploy our
code on this web app on the application
with the help of
devops practices that is we will try to
go i mean we will use some devops
practices to get our code to pull our
code from uh from github and we will try
to uh push it into our web app so that
our website would be running on azure
web app okay so this is the scenario
that we will try to discuss out here so
the objectives in this lab will be what
so we will first create an azure web app
and let's go one by one so the first
objective is to create an azure web app
so we will try to do that okay and then
we will come to the next steps correct
so let's try to create an azure web app
first okay
um
yeah so let's go and do it so i'll just
go to portal and i will try to do this
right
esl yeah sure
so i'll just go to
uh i'll just
yeah
so what i'll do is
i will just go to web app so if i have
to use web apps i'll search for app
services in azure okay and then i'll
create a web app so i'll just create an
app service here that is in azure web
app
right
now of course we have to create a
resource in azure inside a subscription
and a resource group so we have a
subscription now you can name a resource
group we can create a resource loop so
let's say i will create a resource group
with any name
right so
and of course i think the
link for the video would be provided to
you guys so you don't have to worry
about it plus apart from this for this
complete lab for this complete uh thing
that i am going to do here i have the
lab step step-by-step lab document for
this available so we can share you this
also so that um
like after this class you can do it
after uh by listening to my recording
also or um you can just do it by
referring to the lab steps also that are
given out there okay
so let's uh create this web app so i'll
just give the name uh to this web app so
before that i will just try to create a
resource group so let me try to create a
resource group with this name any name i
can give to my resource group now
then i will just give the web app name
so i'll i'll just give the web app name
is
let's say
my
web app
zero zero zero zero nine
i can give any name but uh i need to
make sure that that is a unique name
because it is associated with
with a domain that is say dot assure
websites.net so it has to be a unique
name okay so i'll just give it
myweb.0009.azurewebsites.net
now
see i want to deploy a code on this web
app i can also deploy a docker container
but i want to deploy a code so i'll say
code now see in this scenario as i've
already mentioned that on the on
premises the company's
data centers are running on windows
servers using php runtime stack so when
they are trying to use azure web app to
run their website so they so we will
also try to uh run it on
windows server using php runtimes tech
also here in web app
right so we will choose the runtime
stack
as say
php 7.4 maybe and we'll go with windows
os windows operating system now region i
can choose any
where my web app would be created so
let's say i go with east u.s
now uh this is important um yeah so
europe i'll just park your question at
the end i'll come to that okay i hope
that should be good right
because uh i would like to uh go on with
this topic that we are in right now
yeah so uh zone redundancy uh sorry uh
before that see app service plan guys so
now what is this app service plan so i
told you that we get azure web app in a
pass based manner that is platform as a
service component now something that you
are going to get in a pass-based manner
so for that you don't have to manage the
servers okay you don't have to manage
the infrastructure so probably the
underlying vms that would be created on
which your web app would be running
those are something that you don't have
to manage guys so see you will be
deciding on the infrastructure that you
need for your web app
that is the vcpu capacity the ram
capacity the hard disk storage for your
web app is something that you will
decide but you don't have to manage that
you don't have to manage the underlying
server with the
cpu capacity the ram capacity the hard
disk storage you don't have to manage
that guys why i mean you don't have to
install the security updates on that or
you don't have to patch those servers
why because the provider microsoft will
be doing it for you here right but then
of course you will have to decide on the
capacity that you need for your web app
the ram capacity the cpu capacity the
storage capacity of course those are
things that you don't have to manage but
you'll have to decide on that that how
much you need it because you have to pay
for it so you should be able to decide
it and that you can decide with
something called as an app service plan
okay you can give name to your app
service plan and then you can you can
just uh choose from the different app
service plans that you have in picture
okay so you can just choose from these
different app service plans guys
yeah so uh
fine so you can just choose from these
different app service plans one of the
app service plan as per your choice
right so let me just put it here guys
what do you understand by an app service
plan and
i will just try to
note down here right so see app service
plan will provide you the underlying
infrastructure as i told you it can be
running on one or more vm instances so
here you can decide that how many uh
vcpus ram capacity or the storage you
would like to have for your web app
correct and then
that would be running on one or that
should be running on one or more vm
instances correct behind the scenes a vm
would be created or more than one vm can
be created on which your
web app would be running with the
underlying capacity okay so it's a pass
so no patching no updates no os
management you will need and of course
the underlying vm that would be created
on which your web app would be running
you will not be able to do rdp or ssh to
it that means if it's a windows vm you
cannot
connect to it using remote desktop
protocol or if it's a linux vm you
cannot connect to it using ssh correct
because
it is offered to you in a pass based
manner so you cannot uh
do any changes by connecting to it
because it is not offered to you in an
infrastructure as a service mode correct
so you cannot do rdp or ssh to it right
guys so let's just see this so you can
go with any app service plans guys so
let's say if you you have different
options like with f1 app service plan so
these are preferred for development or
testing environments for less demanding
workloads you have these app service
plans with every app service plan you
will get the underlying capacity like
say with f1 app service plan you will
get 1gb of memory 60 minutes per day is
something that you can run your web app
with this app service plan that means
you can run only for 60 minutes a day
not more than that okay and this is
offered to you free of cost
okay
now here you get 1gb of ram capacity and
that is how it goes and 1gb of hard disk
storage also okay guys then if you go
with d1 app service plan so of course
here you will get again 1gb of ram
capacity 1gb of hard disk storage and of
course shared infrastructure so vcpus
would be shared and here also and
you can run your web app here for 240
minutes a day that means uh it is like
four hours a day only and uh you would
be charged
683.71 rupees per month okay this is an
estimated cost since i have created in
i'm from india location so i can see it
in rupees um if you are in from
different locations you will see it in
your country's currency here the costing
then the custom domain feature is
supported here guys so let me tell you
here see uh when you create your web app
you get a default uh domain that is dot
azure websites.net but what if you want
to do change it if you want to change
this domain name so uh you can do this
you can change your domain name
if you go with
d1 app service plan because that is
supported there if you don't want to
change your domain name you do not
change it right but if you want to
change it then with d1 app service plan
you can change it with f1 you cannot
change it right and with b1 you again
can change it plus you can have secured
here also because it is
http s is supported instead of http
because ssl also is supported here
okay other features are you get 10 gb of
hard disk storage uh 100 1.75 gb of ram
capacity and 100 total acu's you will
get now guys what do you understand by
100 ac use so when they had a
calculation uh the acu is nothing but
azure compute unit and it's a
combination of cpu iops and network
bandwidth correct
so when they had the calculation so they
came out with that uh total hundred
acu's is equivalent to one core of cpu
okay so 100 acu's is equivalent to one
core of cpu and you pay for every acu
okay so you can you can just think of
hundred acus as one core of cpu so here
you will get 100 acus and of course this
also supports manual scaling guys now i
just gave you an example of flipkart
amazon sale days during their sale days
the load on their website increases so
you have to increase the number of
instances on which the website is
running so that the website is not
heavily loaded and so that it
performance doesn't go down or so that
the website doesn't crashes so the
number of instances should be increased
probably i mean ideally you would want
that to increase in an automated fashion
right and then when the load decreases
you would also like that those instances
to be reduced in an automated fashion
why guys because so that so that
you don't have to pay for them when they
are not required correct so automatedly
you should be able to increase or
decrease it so that your web app
supports guys but with this app service
plan that is b1 app service plan it
supports you to increase or decrease the
number of instances on which your web
app would be running
but
here it is manual scaling that it
supports no auto scaling supported with
this app service plan with b1 app
service plan anyways with f1 and d1 even
not even manual scaling is also not
supported there but with b1 manual
scaling is supported but up to three
instances only and no auto in auto
scaling supported here and up to three
instances means right now if your web
app is running on just one vm behind the
scenes now instance means a virtual
machine so right now if your web app is
running on one instance so you can
increase it to two or two three maximum
three you cannot go beyond three okay so
that is what you can do and that also
you will have to manually scale here
auto scaling is not supported here okay
okay so fine am i am i audible to others
yeah manu saying can't hear you
i hope i am audible to others
yeah
disguise can you please confirm yeah so
i'm audible to others so maybe problem
at manusan okay good fine thank you uh
and i hope you are there you are
listening to me so
yes guys so this is manual scaling uh
that feature is supported with b1 app
service plan correct
now
if you go to production and let's say if
you go to s1 app service plan what
features you will do you will get here
so it supports 1.75 gb of ram capacity
100
acu's uh you'll get and custom domain
ssl features supported as i told you 50
gb of hard disk storage you'll get and
guys here auto scaling is supported so
see when i say auto scaling so it
doesn't mean that
automatically the instances will
increase on your web app right no it is
if you want uh you can right with this
app service plan you can increase the
number of instances in an automated
fashion with this app service plan for
your web app but if you don't want you
don't increase it simple as that but
here you can automatically increase your
instances on which your web app would be
running to up to 10 instances beyond 10
you cannot go let's say if you hit a
condition that if the cpu load on my
available instance of the web app if it
is greater than 90 then then create one
more web app instance so from 1 2 would
be created when the load crosses 90
and then from 2 3 instances can be
created like from 2 it will go to three
if again the load hits that threshold of
ninety percent and then from three it
can go to four from flow it can go to
five as the condition is satisfied of uh
ninety percent load right likewise you
can go up to ten guys but if the load on
those 10 instances again crosses 90
percent then can you create a 11th
instance the answer is no you cannot why
because the upper limit is 10 instance
is only here correct so that is what is
the point then here you can do daily
backups that is you can you can actually
backup your web app data for 10 times
daily here 10 times daily guys you can
if you wish you can you can you can have
a backup for once daily also or you may
not have a backup at all but if you want
to have a backup then maximum you can
have it for 10 times daily you cannot go
beyond 10 times okay
with this app service plan then there's
a load balancer in a show called as
traffic manager so even if you have your
two web apps in two different regions
let's say one in east us one in west us
so you can balance the load across those
two web apps using a traffic manager so
let's say if you have your website
running in two servers one is in east us
and one in west us um then your web app
can actually uh what manage the traffic
then your traffic manager can do what it
can actually balance the traffic across
these two web apps that are in different
regions that are running your same
website right so that is possible um if
you are using this app service plan so
you can uh
you can uh what you can use the traffic
manager functionality with this web app
also
okay which is a kind of load balancer
that can balance the load across the
region skies right
so that is there now there is one thing
that is remaining here that is staging
slots guys and in fact we are going to
use staging slots in our lab so what do
you understand by staging slots guys so
if i if i show you my scenario see i
i've told you you need to determine
how you can implement devops practices
by leveraging web apps deployment slots
and that is the second step also guys we
will create a staging deployment slot
now what do you understand by staging
deployment slot guys so guys when you
when you um
create your web app or when you when you
will push your code to the web app so is
it like you directly push the code to
production let's say if you are a
software engineer if you are a developer
um
you are a developer
so
um
you will uh you you will create a
software so will you will you direct
when you code your software and you
create a software so you do directly
push it into
production are you first put it in the
staging stage uh that is in the lower
environment let's say development qa
testing environment uh uat and then if
it works fine then you push it to
production how you go about it guys
do you directly push your uh code into
production that is your software into
production or you first test it in the
lower environments how you go about it
can you tell me how you do it so you of
course you push it
where directly into production or you
test it in the lower environments first
you test it in the lower environments
correct right so you test it in the
lower environments and if it works fine
guys out there then you push it into
production correct then you push it into
production so those lower environments
are nothing but here so for running
those lower environments you need
something called as a staging deployment
slot so you can create the lower
environments with the help of staging
deployment slots staging slots and once
it works fine your web app or your code
then you push it to production right so
with this app service plan you can
create up to up to
five staging slot that is that means you
can create up to five lower environments
if you want you can just create one
lower environment also but at the max
you can create five lower environments
five staging slots and
you can test your code out there and
then if it works fine you can move it to
production correct so that is how you go
so for uh vikram saying for backup do we
need extra storage uh yes of course
vikrant we need extra storage for backup
and there is a service called as
recovery service vault in azure which
provides you with that extra storage so
that that is recovery service vault is a
service that is again offered to you in
a pass-based manner that is platform as
a service mode so there the storage it
uses the storage behind the scene that
is the storage in azure only and it will
store your
web app data out there right so yes of
course the additional storage space is
required and that is being given by a
service that is called as recovery
service vault in azure and that uses the
azure storage only correct is it clear
vikrant i hope it is
right so that is how you go guys and
this is what you uh get it in uh
the
uh with the s1 app service plan if it is
clear uh
vikrant you can put a yes is there any
match limit on the storage no there is
no such max limit correct uh why because
that is offered to you in a pass-based
manner uh with azure recovery services
while you get that recovery um uh like
the storage space for for for storing
the backup so there is no limit uh you
can store any amount of storage but yes
when you are creating a web app so of
course with different app service plan
you have different storage space here
that is given to you like this has 50 gb
of storage space right so that is there
associated with storage accounts correct
quick run yeah
so uh
so choose a big data storage technology
in assure not required also because
anyways with your nirupam with your
azure storage with your blobs binary
large objects you you can store any
amounts of data like in aws they say
that s3 bucket can can store unlimited
amount of data here in azure also they
say that i mean you can store any amount
of data in a short blobs right
yeah so that is there anyways 50 gb can
be free debug but then in free tier you
get
like 200 dollars for one month free when
you create an azure account right so uh
in that you can you can you can go
beyond that size also
right here 50 gb is not free here 50 gb
debug is not free it is like with this
app service plan you will get 50 gb of
this storage right here you will get 50
gb of disk storage but it is not free
okay here uh with this s1 app service
plan you will be charged three rupees
three one five five indian national
currency rupees per month you would be
charged on an estimated basis right but
in aws we can store a 5 gb by default
yes so that is with aws turret that is
st storage okay here also assure you and
you azure you have storage that is we
have different types of storage like
blobs uh in that blobs you have page
blocks blob blob append blobs we will
not go into that because we are not into
that topic but yes of course you can
store your data there but if you are if
you are creating a web app here also you
will get the hard disk storage uh of 50
gb with this app service plan but for
this complete app service plan you will
be charged this much per month right if
you go with other app service plan let's
say p1 v2 you will get 250 gb of hard
disk storage right
and up to 20 staging slots so based on
the app service plan you decide you will
get the storage space right deepak right
rahul i hope that is clear
fine so that is good there right okay
then uh yes okay
good so that is how you go guys uh so
that is what it is then there is one
more option um that is called as
isolated guys so of course we are not
going to use this isolated plan but let
me tell you what is this so isolated app
service plan guys it is going to create
separate dedicated data center for you
so if you choose isolated app service
plan so it is going to create a separate
dedicated data center for you where your
applications can be provisioned really
really costly guys okay so you can
provision your applications really
costly here because a separate dedicated
data center will be deployed for you
guys okay so you deploy your application
in separate dedicated data center uh
which can have on-premises connectivity
and you can access your application in
the intranet environment this way right
so you can access your application in
the intranet environment because it is
going to create a separate dedicated
data center for you correct anyways
we'll go with production
plan and we'll go with s1 app service
plan right so we'll apply it
and i hope i have told you about the
different plans right guys then there is
something called as no scaling can be
done to the underlying infrastructure
now what do you understand by this
no scaling can be done to underlying
infrastructure okay no like snowball in
aws rahul you have something called as
azure data box disk
azure data box disk in azure like
snowball in aws okay
like snowball in aws you have azure data
box disk
okay
fine
fine so here what i told you is that you
cannot change the underlying
infrastructure you cannot modify the i
mean i'm saying you cannot no changes
can be done to the underlying
infrastructure now what do you mean by
this guys so let's say if you choose
this s1 app service plan
which is going to give you what
if you choose s1 app service plan guys
so this s1 app service plan is going to
give you 1.75 gb of ram capacity what if
you want to modify this capacity one
from 1.75 gb to to let's say 3gb can you
do this with s1 app service plan the
answer is no you cannot modify this plan
but then guys what you can do is you can
change the app service plan you can
change the app service plan from s1 you
can change it to p1 v2 and then
you will get 3.5 gb of ram capacity so
this is something you can do but you
cannot modify an app service plan okay
so that is the point and if you change
an app service plan guys so that is
called as that is called as what that is
called as vertical scaling okay so if
you change an app service plan you can
do it while your web app is running on
the go you can change the app service
plan and that is called as vertical
scaling guys that can be done with the
option called as scale up in web apps in
azure so here you can increase or
decrease the sizing of an app service
plan correct
and guys the other thing that is i
talked to you about the horizontal
scaling wherein you can increase the
number of instances of that size only so
that is called that can be achieved with
scale out that is called as horizontal
scaling so here you are increasing the
number of instance count so as i told
you uh when you want to increase the
number of instance count of a particular
app service plan let's say app s1 app
service plan one instance would be
running and with auto scale feature of
azure web app you can increase that one
instance to two two two three three two
4 and up to 10 here with this s1 f
service plane so this is called as
horizontal scaling guys and if you
change the app service plane from s1 to
p1 v2 or any other plan so that is
called as vertical scaling okay
horizontal scaling again explain okay so
see horizontal scaling means see
your azure web app would be created and
that would be running on one virtual
machine behind the scene one instance
that means behind the scene so tomorrow
let's say you are you are having a flip
card or amazon kind of a business
wherein the entire business is dependent
on their website so during their sale
days let's say flipkart big billion days
ms amazon's great indian sale the load
on their website is not same that
increases that shoots up like anything
so during that time the number of
instances on which the website of their
website is running should also increase
otherwise the website will go down or it
performance may deteriorate
so to increase the number of instances
and of course they should be increasing
in automated fashion so to do that what
you can do is you can have the
auto scale feature of azure web app that
can be utilized there so here you can
just specify that if the if the traffic
on the available instances if it goes
beyond 80
so you increase the number of instances
and
and if the if the uh yeah so if there is
one instance and the traffic goes beyond
80 so second instance would be created
if the traffic on that also crosses
eighty percent so a third instance would
be created and so on guys and so on this
can this can go on but then if there are
ten instances and the traffic on them
again goes beyond eighty percent so
eleventh instance will not be created
here okay because the upper limit is 10
instances so this increasing the number
of instances as per the load uh though
all the same in all those instances all
those vms will be of the same size guys
or when the load reduces you decrease
the number of vms so this is called as
horizontal scaling okay when you
increase or decrease the number of vms
of the same size and what is vertical
scaling so here you change the power of
the vm itself here you change its power
from this capacity to this capacity you
don't increase the number of vms but you
change the power of the vm
okay
right rahul is it here yes if i want to
go beyond 10 instances go with p1v2
app service plan and here you can go up
to 20 instances if you want to go beyond
that also go with other app service plan
maybe um
let's say p3 v3 so here also so see you
can go with 20 here also but then if you
want to go beyond 10 you can be on 20
you can see the additional option and
whichever offers you beyond 20 you can
go with that correct so that is how you
go about it uh right atnu uh so if there
are 10 um is the limit with s1 if you
want to go beyond 10 you can go with
let's say p1v2 which will give you up to
20 instances limit okay i hope that is
clear
right guys so that is there fine so
that's there
um
so scaling of app service plan that is
horizontal scaling can be manual or auto
scaling right guys and at least one vm
instance should be running inside your
app service plan because your app
service plan cannot run with zero
instances with zero vm so your web app
cannot run with zero vm
right
yeah that is dependent on different
factors vikrant so based on the
availability of that also that
particular size of vm right and how much
is the demand of that that can vary
correct okay
we can't customize our plans with indian
instances no you cannot customize your
plans with needed instances you will
have to choose from these instances only
or otherwise you can raise a ticket with
microsoft and ask for a customized plan
okay
write deepak so you can do that
with s1 it will not increase but you can
always ask for the customized plan to
provide it to you right rahul
with s1 it cannot modify s1 for you okay
fine so that is there okay so that is
good and then we go next deployment and
that's it so we we went with this plan
which plan guys we went with s1 app
service plan okay
then we will go next and next again and
monitoring if you want you can but not
required anyways
okay so how to protect passwords with an
azure ad password policy so you can
always do it in azure ready right even
you can change your passwords with
something called a self service password
reset feature nirupam but
just to tell you that is not the topic
of the discussion today if i'll tell you
that i'll not be able to finish this
topic so maybe sometime we can connect
or otherwise i can share you a
documentation how you can change it
right so that will help you nirupam i
hope that is good right because that is
a separate separate thing that is
nowhere related to this topic if i'll
cover that this will not be covered uh
this cannot be covered in the stipulated
time otherwise right i hope you
understand
so monitoring if you want you can you
can uh
enable application insights to
monitor the application okay uh
through application insights monitoring
tool you can do that if you wish to not
required and then you can just say next
and you can create this web app guys
so this is how you can create your web
app now see uh i told you here uh like
in this scenario we first had to create
a web app that's what we are trying to
create here right i hope nirupam
that is good with you that is okay with
you right
i'm not muted
i'm not muted uh can you hear me guys i
hope yes we can hear you again
yeah thank you thank you
okay
latest monitoring tool in azure so you
have something called as azure monitor
and you have something called as uh
application insights which can monitor
the applications for you right and for
other things you have azure monitor and
log analytics workspace so um azure
monitor can keep the logs for 30 days
for free of cost for you
and if you want to keep your locks
beyond 30 days then you can use uh what
you can use the
what
i mean you can with applications you can
use uh azure application uh
listing app insights right so this is
what you can use uh for monitoring
correct of your applications
and if you want to
do the monitoring of other things beyond
30 days if you want to keep your logs
for more than 30 days you can make use
of log analytics workspace which is
again a monitoring tool right
so that is how you can go about it so
see we have created an azure web app now
the next thing is to create a staging
deployment slot because guys as i told
you you will not directly push your code
to production but you will try to push
it to a lower environment first that is
to the staging slot okay so right now we
have our web app in place and if you'll
go to this web app so this is your
production slot and and you will get the
url of your production slot if you if
you put it in your browsers you will see
that your web app is running but there
is no code out there right there is no
application that you have deployed
deployed with your web app so this is
the url of your web app if i'll try to
run it here guys in my browser or if
i'll try to give it to you also and if
you also try to run it uh in your um
browsers i'll paste it on everyone so
you will see uh the default home page
for your web app so your web app is
running but it is waiting for the
content it is waiting for the code okay
so you can push your code into the web
app but as i told you you will not do it
in the production slot and this is your
production slot how you can verify that
you can go to deployment slots and you
will see that this is your production
slot see this is your production slot my
web app zero zero zero nine right so
this is my web app zero zero zero nine
so this is your production slot and you
don't want to push your code to
production so you want to push it to a
staging slot so let's create an staging
slot so let's add a slot so i'll say add
slot here right and i will enter a name
so let's say i give a name as staging
okay i can give it like a uat
environment testing environment whatever
the name you want to give to your
staging slot you can give it i'm just
naming it as staging only and i'll say
what i'll say so so it's name so it's
url will become my web app009
hyphen
staging.azurewebsites.net and i'll say
add and this will add a staging slot and
then i will deploy my code to the
staging slot case
fine so that is what i am going to do
okay
and i will show you that the url of the
staging slot will be different than your
production slot see the url of this
staging slot will be my web app zero
zero zero nine hyphen azure hyphen
staging dot azure websites dot net and
for the production slot it is my web app
zero zero zero nine dot azure websites
dot net so the url of your staging slot
and the production slots
will be different guys they should be
different because they are different
environments otherwise otherwise how can
um i mean how can you call them as
different environments correct so this
is added and from where you can add it
guys so you can just go to deployment
slots and you can say add slot when you
say add slot you just give the name of
the staging slot and you say add and
this is how it is done simple as that
right so once you have the staging slot
now i will just go to the staging slot
because i have to push the code out
there in the staging slot so if i click
on the staging slot so i will get the
url of the staging slot as i told you it
would be
not the same as your production slot but
it would be web app name myweb 0009
hyphen staging dot azurewebsites.net so
the staging word comes in here and this
makes your url different from the
production url correct so this makes
your url different from the production
url now let's say if i run this
then here also my web app would be
running fine correct so from here also
you can see your web app is running
and it says your web app is running and
waiting for your content right so you on
your staging slot now you can push the
content now you can push the code and so
before pushing the code of course what
you will be doing guys is you will be
executing the task number three that is
you will configure the web app
deployment settings of your staging slot
of course you will configure the
deployment settings of your staging slot
before pushing the code to that slot
so that the code can run fine out there
so we have to configure that first and
then we'll have to push the code and of
course i'll be push i'll be configuring
the staging slot only not the production
slot because i have to push the code to
the staging slot first right so i'll go
to the configuration settings on the
staging slot so see i am in the staging
slot you need to make sure that you are
in the staging slot and here you will go
to deployment center in the deployment
option you will go to deployment center
guys and what you will do is you will
just create a repository you will
configure the deployment settings for
this staging slot so that you can push
the code in the next step onto the
staging slot so guys you will need a
repository okay wherein you can push the
code so you'll need a repository for the
staging slot wherein in the next step
you will push the code and that code
would be available on your web app
staging slot right so
you can choose any repository so you can
go with continuous deployment ci cd
wherein you can go with github bitbucket
localgate azure repo so you can go with
manual deployment also push command that
is you can go with external gate one
drive dropbox so let's say i'll go with
continuous deployment because i have to
use the devops command
right and i'll go with continuous
deployment and i'll go with local git as
the repository so when i say local git
repo right so and then i save this then
i save this so i will get a uri i'll get
a url
with that uri i can push the code to
this local git repository in the next
step and once the code will come here on
this local git repository
once the code will
come on this local git repository so it
would be available on my web apps
staging deployment slot in the lower
environment of my web app right guys so
this is you have got the git clone url
now of course you can copy it and you
can put it you can you can save it
somewhere because this is something this
uri is something i'm going to need it in
the next step when i'll be pushing my
code into the web app okay so i'll be
pushing the code onto the staging
deployment slots repository this local
git url
and then it would be available on my
staging slot simple as that
so but then guys in the next step when i
will be trying to access this repository
to push the code onto this repository of
the staging slot of my web app
so
there should be some username and
password that should be there for this
repository for accessing this repository
otherwise anyone and everyone can access
this repository and put the code out
there whosoever will have the link of
this repository right so i need some
username and password for this
repository so that with
authenticated access only someone can
push the code on this repository right
so for that so for that what i'll do is
i'll go to localgit ftps credentials
here and i will create a username and
password for this repository so that
when i'll try to push the code on this
repository so it will ask me for the
username and password of this repository
and if i'll supply the correct username
and password only then i'll be able to
push the code on this repository so it
would be a secured access to this
repository so we'll have a secured
access to the repository by giving the
username and password for this
repository so see user scope you can put
the username let's say i put the
username as pursutham and the password
of my choice case so i'm just giving a
password here
okay
so i'm just supplying
the password and this username and
password i'll have to give in the next
step to push the code on this repository
so that the code would be available on
my web app without this username and
password i will not be able to push the
code on my uh
on my web apps repository correct so
i'll just save it
okay
the pycharm is there okay you can use
that as well
if it's there
right rahul
okay please i'm not seeing uh so you can
see it
etob others are seeing my video so you
can maybe log out and log back again
that can help you
felix you may log out and log in again
that may help you
okay so see now i have added the
username and password and again i have
saved it correct guys so this is done so
i have done step number
uh which three here i've configured the
web app deployment settings now i'll
come to step number four and i'll deploy
the code to the staging slot so guys how
i'll deploy the code so i can do it with
something called as powershell in azure
cloud shell so this is a cloud shell
which is integrated with your azure
account so here with the help of
commands i will deploy the code to this
uh deployment slot to the local git
repository of this
staging slot right so i'll just open
this up this partial machine here
okay by clicking here and then in this
partial machine i'll try to deploy the
code guys okay with the help of some
devops commands okay
so with the help of devops commands we
will try to deploy the code onto the
repository of my
azure web apps
deployment slot right
how is git's staging area useful see we
are using the staging area of our web
app not the git okay so this is the
staging slot of my azure web app so of
course i'm creating the staging so that
i've created the staging slot so that i
don't push the code directly on the
production slot because if i do it and
if the code doesn't run fine out there
so i had been problem so of course you
do this practice that is when you create
a software in your company also you
first try to push it in the lower
environment you test it out and if it
runs fine then you push it to production
so here also we are having a lower
environment in the name of staging
deployment slot and we will push our
code into this lower environment first
and then if it runs fine we will move it
to production and for pushing the code
into this lower environment we have
created a repository with this lower
environment so from git hub we will get
the code through this partial machine so
i am going to get the code from github
onto my powershell machine in azure and
then from partial machine inertia i'm
going to push the code into my um what
into the repository of my lower
environments of the web app into the
repository of my staging deployment slot
of the web app yes guys and that way the
code would be running on my web app
staging deployment slot right is it
clear nero pump so that is how we are
going to do
how do we know which version of code the
web app is running
so whichever version of the code uh you
are going to bring in or you are going
to deploy it on your web app that is
what your web app would be running right
so code would be from your end con i am
going to get a code from
github and i am going to deploy that on
my web app right but yes the uh
runtime stack that you are using that is
php runtime stick for that the version
you have chosen that it has given you an
option to choose the version for that so
we have gone with php 7.8 okay
so that is there
i hope that is clear con if there is any
other question other than this you
please ask me if this is clear you
please
can respond yes or no
so now uh
robert is saying yes
yes so now uh let's
see application code application code
will be your i mean see uh application
code is something that you are going to
decide right which code you are you you
can put any version of the code
application code on azure web app that
is up to you so that depends on your
application right and which version of
the
application code you want to deploy
whatever version you want to deploy you
can just deploy that right
will that be the master version of the
code in the local git so of course we
can decide we will put it on the master
version yes we will do it on the master
version right
yes we will do it we that would be the
master version of the code in the local
git that we are going to do yeah you got
it good
so you can you can deploy your code in
many ways uh like nirupam you can deploy
it in azure web apps first in the local
environ like in the lower environments
and then to the production slot or you
can deploy your code onto a virtual
machine also directly which is offered
to you as an infrastructure as a service
manner right so you can run your
application your websites on virtual
machine also you can run it on
containers also containers with
kubernetes you can you can orchestrate
that also so these are what deploy
different deployment types that you can
have it in azure of deploying your code
you can deploy it in a in the form of a
virtual machine um
or different weights i can just put it
here also uh so i'll just put it for you
right uh just give me a moment
so see uh i'll just put it for you here
so see app deployment different modes so
you can deploy an app on your virtual
machine but of course you need to manage
the server os there because uh
because this is offered to you as an
infrastructure as a service mode right
then you can make use of app service
that's what we are doing out here so you
can deploy your app there so no need to
manage the server in our case here when
we are using web app so this is like
using elastic bean stock service in aws
like you have web app in azure correct
um then you can go with you can deploy
it in the form of code or docker
container we are doing it in the form of
code then you can also do it using
microservices application so you using
containers so assuming your developer
has broken a big application that is a
bonolithic application to microservices
okay so uh what you can do is uh so uh
you breaking down the big application
into small components is called as micro
services right so you can also run them
in the form of containers and then on
the orchestration of the containers you
can increase or decrease the number of
containers and you can provide the
communication between containers using
something called as azure kubernetes
right so there you don't need any server
management app deployment is faster you
can also integrate it with ci cd
pipeline much efficiently right so that
is fully auto managed by kubernetes so
guys and in fact nowadays i'll tell you
companies are normally going for pass
based manner that is using app service
or micro services app rather than going
for vm based deployment for your
websites or your
applications why guys because there you
have to manage these servers and
companies would like to concentrate on
their core business rather than managing
the servers right like let's say netflix
is running on aws so of course it is it
must not be using the iis mode correct
because in that they will also have to
manage the server so what these
providers tell you is tells you is that
um
you you you just do one thing is i mean
you concentrate on your business and let
the infrastructure related stuff let the
management part of your infra be taken
care by by us let let us take care of
your virtual machines also right so that
way the companies can concentrate just
on their core business let's say if a
financial organization is that they can
just take care of their financial
business rather than concentrating on
managing the servers so that can be
taken care of by the provider and that's
why companies are more towards going
with pass-based services or containers
kubernetes rather than going with vms
that is isb services that is
infrastructure as a service components
and let me tell you guys azure as for as
far as the gartner is concerned which is
the research organization so that uh
according to gartner
azure
leads the quadrant in the past based
services right and of course aws does it
in isb services in azure does it in the
past based services it leads the
quadrant okay so it it is the leader in
that okay
fine so that is there so now i hope that
is clear this is ci cd so any change in
code in repo can be pushed into staging
is that correct correct yeah so any
change in the repo can be pushed to uh
your staging also you'll have to you'll
have to execute the command again
right we are using the ci cd commands
here we are not creating a ci cd
pipeline here
right so we are just using these uh uh
uh
this commands that is devops commands
okay
right so if you change something where
we are not creating a pipeline here so
if you change something in your code in
the uh in the in the github repository
so you need to again execute these
commands any code would be pushed in
your uh in your azure web app right
that's what happens there so now guys
let's uh push the code here so first
i'll push the code into this repository
and then i would be pushing the code
onto my um
but onto my uh
web app correct so first i will
pull the code from
github onto this
powershell machine so i am just going to
use this command that is git clone that
is the devops commands git clone and
then i'm going to give the uh
link of the repository that is
github.com azure samples php docs hello
world so from there the code would be
cloned onto my powershell machine see it
has now been cloned on my powershell
machine
if i just go to this repository guys so
i can show you that code right i'll just
new tab to the right i'll say and if i
go to github so this is a public
repository you can use this repository
right publicly on the github i can give
you the link also of the same so see in
this repository you have three files
that is license readme.md and index.php
now whatever there is there in index.php
that would be displayed on the home page
of my website right so if you see here
there is just a simple code in php that
says echo hello world so on my um web
apps uh home page what would be
displayed it should be echo hello world
correct when i will push this code onto
my azure web app but right now i have
this code on the powershell machine on
my azure powershell machine not on my
web app correct now if you want to see
whether this code is there on your
powershell machine or not um whether the
three files that is readme.md
index.php and
license whether these three files have
been cloned on your partial machine or
not so what you can do is you can just
execute this command set location first
of all we we can just set the location
to this php docs hello world that is the
home location where these three files
are cloned on my machine and then i can
just do ls and i will see those three
file names are present you can see
index.php license and readme.md so they
are there guys so they are there on your
uh powershell machine now the next thing
is
can we run these commands in vm to
update the web app no we cannot because
the underlying vm that would be created
for this web app
for this web app if you are asking for
this web app the vm that is created you
cannot do rdp to that or ssh if it's a
linux vm you cannot do that why because
that is offered to you as a platform as
a service manager other vms yes you can
other vms uh no uh so okay uh like
developer vms okay so if you want to do
it through other vms so they should be a
part of azure maybe but not outside of
azure here uh so again in azure if you
have to do it you would you can run the
powershell machine uh sorry the cloud
shell and then that shell and that you
can go about it right
okay
fine so that's what you can try to do it
okay
so here you need to run the partial in
in in fact in azure also if you want to
do it uh then of course you'll have to
connect to azure first and then you try
to execute it so from your local machine
also like from even from your local
machine that is from your laptop also
with the app api you can connect from
the powershell on your local machine if
you have installed az module that is
azure module of powershell on your local
machine you can connect to the
powershell on your local machine and
then you like say partial on your local
machine if you try to connect so you can
just try to do this you can try to
connect to the powershell on your local
machine you can run it as administrator
on your local machine and once you do
that here uh if you have a z module of
powershell installed on your local
machine so you can connect to your azure
account from here and then you can try
to execute the command from your local
machine also right
and from azure vm also in the same way
okay anyways we are using the integrated
cloud shell with azure that is
having the option of powershell
i hope that is clear right con
okay so
yes so you have it here now uh
yeah yeah great okay thank you yes so
now you have it here now the next thing
is guys uh
what i'll do is uh now see i have to
push these three files onto this staging
slot that is on to the local git
repository of the staging slot so how i
can do it guys so first of all i should
add that remote repository onto this
partial machine and then only i'll be
able to push the commands out there guys
so for that the command is get remote
add see for this partial machine that
local get repository of the staging slot
is a remote repository okay for this
partial machine it is a remote
repository because when the code comes
to your powershell machine it doesn't
mean that the code is available it
doesn't mean that the code is available
in your web app in the staging
deployment slot of your web app so it
doesn't mean that the code is available
there guys but the code is just
available uh where on the powershell
machine only right now on the powershell
machine
through powershell machine if you want
to push that code to your remote
repository to the repository of the
staging deployment slot to the local git
repository of the staging deployment
slot so you have to say git remote ad
because for this partial machine that
local git repository of this changing
deployment slot is a remote repository
so i'll say get remote add and i'll give
the deployment username now it can be
any name guys it has to be a unique name
so i'll give a name let's say i'll give
the same name as pursutham but then as i
told you it can be any name it it need
not to be that username that i had
created for my local git repository but
it should be any unique name i'm just
naming it as pursutam only and then the
get clone url so here you need to
specify the url of your uh
local get repository of the deployment
slot right so um
so see
you can
you can just go here in the settings and
you had this repository link get clone
url link in fact you have copied it in
the notepad also you can copy it from
here and you can put it here guys so you
can just put it here um
you can paste it here and you can say
enter
and this will add so this has added your
repository that is the staging
deployment slot uh slots repository it
has added it on your partial machine now
once it is added guys once it is added
what you can do is you can push the code
right so you can just push the code okay
so for that the command is get push okay
get push and then you'll have to specify
that deployment username that is the
unique name that you have used in the
above step that is for them and you are
going to push it on the master branch if
someone was asking me so uh yes i'm
pushing it on my master branch of this
local git repository and i'll say git
push
that is the deployment username portion
and then master and as soon as i do it
guys it asked me
for the username and password of this
repository see if you remember we had
created a username and password for this
repository for a secured access to this
repository wherein the username we had
given to show them and the password i
had given it of my choice so i'm just
going to supply that username and
password to actually login to this
repository okay
to actually push the code to this
repository so i'll give the username and
then it will ask me for the password and
let me tell you i am going to supply a
password but guys you don't see it here
because um it is a password so but i am
typing it here i have typed it and
i am just saying enter and this will
push the code on my repository this
should push the code on my repository
that is on the
local get repository of your azure web
app that is of the staging slots
repository yes so this is what it is
trying to push it and once it is pushed
guys so the code will come to the
repository of your deployment slot and
once the code is there on your web apps
deployment slot so that means the code
is there on your web app on your web
apps staging deployment slot right so
yes it has been pushed guys it is done
now i can check it must be there so i
can just close this and now if you go to
that uh what if you go to that staging
deployment slots url uh wherein the
default home page for was running so
guys now you tell me if i refresh it
what code should be displayed here the
code that we have pushed and which is
that code which is that code it should
be displaying what hello world yes or no
it should be displaying hello world do
you agree with me or not
you can type in a yes or no
yes right so we will see that so i'll go
to this deployment slot the the the the
uh
staging deployment slot and i'll just
refresh it and it should show hello
world to me i'll just wait for this to
show the hello world to me you can see
it it is hello world but what about the
production slot guys so production slot
production slot is still showing your
home page you can refresh it it's still
showing the home page why because you
have deployed the code onto the staging
slot not the production slot in the
lower environment not the
production environment right so now you
need to push it to production so see now
since it is working fine in the lower
environment so now you can push it to
production right so since it is running
fine in the lower environment so deploy
code to the staging deployment slot and
if it runs fine you swap the staging
slot so you move whatever this is there
on the staging slot you move it to
production and whatever is there on the
production slot you move it to staging
so that's what we'll do now different
types of repositories in azure and what
is azure pipeline so azure pipeline is a
ci cd tool wherein if you make any
change to your code that code gets
updated automatically that is used in
your
in your agile software model correct so
you create a pipeline you do the code
deployment that is uh you you go you
commit the code you you deploy like you
compile it you execute it and you deploy
it uh
you release it so everything is done and
a pipeline is created let's say if you
change the code now change you change
something in the code so all the cycle
will be automatically done that is done
with azure ci cd pipeline right nerupa i
hope that is
clear uh
so then see what you can do is now you
need to swap the slot so that you can do
so what you can do is uh and what are
the different repositories supported so
there are many uh so i've shown you you
have local gate you have azure repos you
have uh
kit uh you have you have many other
repositories that are there correct so
uh
that are also supported here right i've
shown you those repositories okay now
see we have to swap the staging slots
right so if i go to the staging slot and
let me go to the production slot to just
show you the repository okay before that
let me swap these slots okay so i am in
this
uh
i can go to my production slot first
right so i can just go to the production
slot and i will say swap slots here i'll
say swap and i will swap the production
with staging correct okay and before
that i can just show you the different
repositories so if in the production
slot you go uh you will find the
different types of repositories again so
you have as you was asking so you have
github bitbucket localgate azure repost
external gate one drive dropbox so you
have different repositories guys and yes
so you can use that correct so now let's
swap the staging slots with the
production slot and projection slot with
the staging slot so i'll go to staging
deployment slot and i'll say swap and as
soon as i say swap so the production
will be swapped with staging and staging
with production
yeah enoch you can try to do that of
course all right but of course here we
are not going to do that because um
it's not in the uh discussion here and
of course
we have to do this first correct okay to
finish off the things in time
so what we'll do is we will just swap
the slots so i'll do slap
but then of course you can try to do
that surely
right so performing the swap between the
star slots that is staging and the
production okay and once that is done
guys so you will have that hello uh
world whatever the code is running on
your swap staging slot uh then that
would be running on your production slot
right guys
just a matter of
minutes it is
and then you will see that
right enoch so you can do that i think
so guys after this step is done so we'll
be done with this swapping the staging
slot also and then i can also show you
how you can do the auto scaling of your
web app that is horizontal scaling when
the load increases on your web app in an
automated fashion right so if there is
one instance of the web app that is
running now with auto scaling how you
can make it how you can increase it to
two uh in an automated fashion right so
that is something that i'll try to tell
you
so this is done and now you can go to
your production slot so here the default
home page was there now you can refresh
it and you see your code is deployed on
the production slot now guys so
congratulations you have your code
running on the uh production slot now
right running on your web app correct
and staging will have default home page
correct so if you refresh the staging
slot it will show the default home page
so whatever was that then on the
production comes to staging and whatever
was there on the staging goes to
production okay so you have hello world
you have your code running on the
production slot so all good guys so this
is done now see when i want to go to
scaling i'll just show you uh in the you
can have two types of scaling as i
already told you guys that is a vertical
scaling and a horizontal scaling correct
so vertical scaling means changing the
power of an uh web app that is changing
the app service plan okay uh wherein it
will increase or decrease the power of
your app service plan that is the number
of vcpus or the ram capacity or the
storage space right so you can do it and
you can term it as vertical scaling and
of course that would be manual and in
horizontal scaling with the same app
service plan of your web app you can
create more instances of that app
service plan correct that is comes under
horizontal scaling and that can be
manual or
automated as well so let me first show
you
so if you if you go to which option
um
let me just see here
you can have scale up so see scale up is
for vertical scaling if you go to scale
up and right now you have s1 app service
plan selected if you want you can change
the plan you can go to p1 v2 and you can
apply it guys so there you will get
total two one zero total acu's and 3.5
gb of ram capacity instead of
1.75 gb of ram capacity so you can
change it guys so this is possible of
course this will have a bit of a
downtime because you are changing the
hardware properties here but that's okay
you can always have that right but then
the next thing that is horizontal
scaling now i will tell you so that
comes in scale out guys before i go and
implement horizontal scaling here i'll
just show you uh if you go to the um
what if you go to which section
to the process explorer
right where is that process explorer
here it is in the monitoring section if
you go to process explorer guys so you
will see that one instance of your web
app is running right
yeah we can also move the slot but not
here directly you'll have to create
another web app with another app service
plan
and from there you can move it here
right from there you can copy it here
rather than moving move is not supported
you can copy it from another web app you
can just copy the code to this app
service plan here right it's not move
here it's only swap here okay
okay so then uh see you have just one
instance of your web app running out
here right so you can see instance id
only one no no doubt two two
environments production and and the
staging environment are running but only
one instance they are running on just
one web app oh sorry they are just
running on one vm that is one instance
so that instance id is given now guys
when i'll do this horizontal scaling so
fro
so you will see this one instance will
change to two so you will see this one
instance will change to do automatically
it will change to two to automatically
right okay so i'll just try to do that
for you
okay so let me just go here and let me
go to scaling
scale out option that is what is
horizontal scaling is
all about so i'll just try to search it
where it is
yeah so here it is in the settings tab
you have scale out you go to scale out
guys and i'll give a matrix so you can
do manual scaling you can manually
increase or decrease the number of
instances or you can go with you can
manually increase or decrease it to
i mean one two three whatever you wish
to or you can do what you can do
auto scaling also so i'll do auto
scaling guys because that makes a lot of
sense even the use cases i've given you
like the flip card amazon their sale
days they can have auto scaling feature
uh and that can cater to their websites
like uh
that way their websites will not go down
or they will be able to handle the
additional load and their performance
will not be deteriorated right so i'll
go with auto scaling here
to show you that and i'll scale based on
a matrix guys right so let's say i'll
scale based on a metric and then i will
add a rule here so now this rule what i
will do it here so what i will say is i
will scale based on a matrix so i will
say current resource okay i want to do
it with current resource and the time
aggregation i'll just go with let's say
maximum and so what i'm trying to do is
i'll say
if the metric name i'll choose this
there are different matrix guys you can
choose in from like data and date out
cpu percentage so i'll just say if the
cpu percentage on my available web app
if it is greater than if it is greater
than let's say if it is greater than
only um
ten percent instead of seventy percent
i'll say ten percent so uh i'll just say
here if
the
traffic on my if the cpu percentage on
my available instance of my web app if
it is greater than 10
for a consecutive duration of just one
minute then
you
uh
on a on a maximum then you increase the
instance count by one okay that is what
i'm specifying here so this means if the
traffic on the available instance of my
web app if it is greater than 10
for a consecutive duration of one minute
then you increase the instance count by
one and keep on checking this condition
every five minutes guys because this is
a very aggressive rule right so keep on
doing it every five minutes okay
so keep on checking the condition every
five minutes okay so that is how you go
about it
so if there is one instance make it two
if the condition hits on those two
instances also then make it three and so
on and guys ideally in your in your
actual scenario you will not test i mean
you will not increase the number of
instances if the cpu percentage goes
greater than 10 but rather if it goes
greater than 70 or 80 percent on your
available vms of your web app uh for a
consecutive duration of not one minute
but more than let's say 10 minutes then
you increase the instance count by one
guys in your actual use cases but here i
want to hit the traffic and i want to
see the result that is the instance
going from 1 to 2 and so on
so i am that's why choosing a small
number as the cpu percentage if it goes
greater than 10 percent for a
consecutive duration of just one minute
uh then you increase the instance count
by one and keep on checking this
condition every five minutes right
okay so that is what you do right so
this is on a maximum so time grain
statistic so on a maximum if the uh
traffic on your instance uh
if it goes greater than uh what
cpu percentage if it graze goes on a
maximum if it goes greater than 10
percent on your available instances for
a duration of one minute then you
increase the instance count by one right
so that is how you go about it and you
say add here and you say add here okay
likewise you can also create a rule to
decrease the number of instances also so
you can say if the traffic is less than
uh whatever ten percent two percent for
a consecutive duration of one minute or
two minutes then you can decrease the
instance count by one also anyways i'm
not giving this condition that condition
but you can give that also guys right
i'm just saying if the uh traffic is
greater than 10 for a consecutive
duration of one minute uh if the cpu
percentage is uh greater than 10 percent
for uh for a consecutive duration of one
minute then you increase the instance
count by one okay
so that's what
you go about it see time grant
statistics it is it is very simple so
this is the aggregation method within
the time grain period uh okay for
example statistic is average and time
grain is p one pt one m means that
matrix will be aggregated every one
minute by taking the average right so
that is what it says yeah so i see i
hope this is clear now i can put this
note for you in the chat window in fact
i can put it for all right i hope this
is clear now so this is the aggregation
method within the time grain period for
example statistic is equals to average
and time grain is pt 1m means that
matrix will be aggregated every one
minute by taking the average but here
the matrix will be aggregated every one
minute not by taking the average but on
a maximum it would be done every one
minute right not by taking the average
but if you choose average then it would
be by average it would be aggregated
every one minute right no
so
that's how it goes okay so now guys see
i have not specified that maximum how
many instances you want so see minimum
one instance should always be running
even if the load on your web app is zero
and by default also one instance is
running but maximum if you specify is
two is the limit so right now one
instance is running you can see here so
if this condition satisfies so one more
instance would be created again on the
two instances if this condition again
hits again is satisfied so a third
instance will not be created because the
maximum you have specified as to only
correct so that is what you do it here
and you save it and you save it so this
is all it is and now you can just hit on
some traffic and you can see that the
instance will go from one to two but it
will not go from two to three because
the max you have specified as two only
right but then yes it will automatically
uh scale up from one to two here right
so for that again i will hit some
traffic on this web app and for hitting
some traffic i'll again go to the
partial machine to the cloud share the
cloud shell i'll go to powershell and i
will try to run
i'll try to
put some traffic in an infinite loop
infinite while loop guys so first i am
giving the resource group name in a
variable that is rg name variable so i
am specifying the web apps resource
group name and then i will take up a
variable that is let's say
web app variable in that i'll get my web
app which is specified uh for which the
resource group name is given in rg name
variable right so that is what i will do
it so
and then i will try to hit the traffic
so
while i'll try to hit the traffic so
i'll say while true that is i'll run an
infinite while loop uh and i will invoke
the web request on the on where i will
invoke the web request on my web app web
apps default host name so dollar web app
is the variable in which you have the
web app so on that web apps default host
name i am just putting a traffic and
infinite traffic guys in an infinite
while loop right and then that condition
will be
satisfied some time that is the uh cpu
percentage will go beyond uh what beyond
ten percent and then a new instance a
second instance would be created here
guys it will take some time uh let's say
two to three minutes and then you will
see that the second instance will come
here so you can just refresh and in some
time you will see the second instance
will be created here guys right as i
said it will take some time at least two
to three minutes right scale to a
specific instance count so this is scale
to a specific instance count means what
that beyond that you don't want to scale
up like here you have one instance of
your web app is running but if i say max
s2 means max s2 means if this condition
is satisfied so if the cpu percentage
goes greater than 10 percent on your one
instance then a second instance would be
created but if the cpu percentage on
that both the instances if it is go if
it goes greater than 10 percent then a
third instance will not be created if
you have specified the maximum instance
count uh to be to be uh two only to be
two only right uh set con i hope that is
clear
what are the pricing tiers available for
app service plan so i have just shown
you when you select an app service plan
you will see the pricing tier right so
when you select any app service plan you
see the pricing tier for that
immediately out there okay so you see
the pricing tier for that immediately
out there and you have production
i mean you have different categories as
test environment production environment
right so you have different out there
correct uh so that is there
anyways i can just duplicate this also
and i can again show you that okay uh
quickly anyways i know we are done with
the time but i'm done with this stuff
guys i'll just now answer your questions
so see we have done the configure and
auto scaling of the azure web app also
and
here we can just see the output in some
time coming that is this one instance
will change to two right so uh yeah so
that's the only thing
that can be seen okay
right
anyways uh so that you are saying about
the app service plan so when you create
your web app you see that app service
plan different app service plan so let's
say if you go to your app services and
you you you create another web app i
mean i'm not creating a web app i'm just
showing it to you so different app
service plans uh you can be able to see
i mean of course you'll have to choose a
resource group for that and see here you
have uh dave test environment production
isolated then in dave test you have
different options right you can go with
that correct so um
yeah so and and every option have a
different pricing available right so of
course uh dave test will be low uh will
be low priced in
plants and then production will be high
price and isolated is the costliest
option that you have right because a
separate dedicated data center would be
created for you
right uh
nirupam yeah and scale down you can also
do it right so you have created your web
app uh so i i just told you the
condition how you can do the scale down
so um if you go to your scale out
stuff here
so you can you can create a custom scale
and you can scale based on a matrix
maybe uh where it is
scale based on sorry scale based or a
matrix if you do and if you add a rule
so you can always add a rule if the cpu
percentage is let's say less than
10 or something for a consecutive
duration of one minute or something then
you can decrease the instance count by
once this is how you can you can
actually do the scale out scale down
condition right
sir can you put a glance on solution
architect among aws in azure see if you
are a cloud architect whether you are
aws architect or you are azure architect
you can become a cloud architect and
then if you do one it is easier for you
to do the other the job role remains the
same um that is you have to do you have
to take the
decisions if if let's say i i give you
five services and
to to implement your solution so you
will have to find out which is the
better one as per the cost is concerned
and as per the other
criterias uh in your organization you
would select the best resource to suit
for that purpose and that is what your
role will be as an architect more of
right
so whether you are an aws architect or
azure architect if you are in aws you
will have to choose from the services
resources in aws whereas in azure you
will have to do it from azure correct so
that is what you do it
right
see now it's done can you see it guys so
congratulations you have your two
instances of the web app running so see
the second instance has been auto
created right nice yes can you see this
guys so it has been uh auto scaled okay
cool yeah so that's how it goes right so
that is what happens here guys right so
that's what happens here right uh just a
second maybe if there are guys if i have
missed on any questions can you please
put it again i would be good to answer
you right so if i've missed on any
questions you can just put in again
right and yeah
yeah the only question i saw that was
that came in that you didn't touch on
was um
somebody asked
whether you could comment on whether
there's more demand for azure versus aws
okay azure versus aws uh so see i mean
see i am an aws certified trainer also
and a microsoft certified trainer also
so if you'll ask me both are good but
then yes let me tell you uh some
differences there is a
there is a big debate going on every now
and then but guys let me tell you if
you'll see uh so if you'll ask me
according uh in the iis quadrant that is
as far as the infrastructure as a
service are concerned aws is marked as
the market leader aws can be better than
azure but with the pass-based services
like web apps azure is uh the market
leader right but then both are really
close to each other and both are really
good and uh today is the age of
multi-cloud platform so uh you should be
good in multiple clouds like you should
be good in market leaders at least aws
and azure because uh in the company
environments it is not that you are
you're just using aws or you're just
using azure you for some services you're
using aws for some you are using azure
and then you are communicating between
them using uh different methods like vpn
gateways and stuff right so uh you
should be good in both if you have to be
an architect or for that matter if you
want to work on cloud so you so today is
the age of multi-cloud platforms um as
far as the understanding part is
concerned more of if you have the
understanding of one cloud platform it's
very easy to adapt to the other one
right because the the the the i mean the
terminologies remains the same it's just
that few ui things and then few options
to use it differs
like right now in aws you have ec2
instances like the virtual machines with
that supports mac operating system also
with azure you don't have a support for
mac op os for creating your vms in fact
last year only awsf came with that so of
course um if you and if you are thinking
that which one is easier to learn uh i
would say both are easy to learn i mean
um
if if you go about it i mean if you put
the efforts both are easy but then um to
start off with you can start with any
but i would prefer either azure or aws
not any other cloud to start off with
that would be my recommendation right
i started with aws first and then uh i
moved on to azure all right so
but then
it's all good it's it's a personal
choice so i really cannot say that aws
is better than azure i've told you the
difference in is quadrant aws is leading
the market in pass quadrant azure is
leading the market but they are not far
away from each other they are near to
each other and yes there was one more
question um so aws co-pilot uh is it is
basically designed for both existing ecs
users and new ecs users okay so um
so it is the first official uh command
line tool for aws elastic container
service was created in 2015
okay and then in december 2019 it was
redesigned from the ground up to make it
easier to deploy your applications on
ecs okay today we are sharing um some of
the progress on the command line tool as
well as uh
it is given an official name as
with the name of aws copilot right so it
is now today named it as aws copilot
right so it was
it started with ecs elastic container
service
that was created in 2015 then in 2019 it
was redesigned from the ground uh to
make it easier to deploy your
applications on ecs and today you are
sharing i mean you have it named it as
the command line tool today is named as
with a new name that is aws pilot which
is designed for both existing ecs users
and the new ecs users also right so
that's what i would like to tell you
about aws co-pilot in short yeah we have
a couple of last questions um
sunil asked when you demonstrated taking
your code deploying it to the production
environment with a swap
how do you then
set up to do the next version of the
code
like that i was curious to know if you'd
work on the production site swap
okay next version of the code of course
you will have to deploy it again or you
can create see if you have the next
version of the code
in this scenario you would like to you
would deploy it again with the help of
the command you would a devops command
you can deploy it
onto your
again first on to your lower environment
and then you would push it to the
production
um or you can create a ci cd pipeline
and then if you just change your code uh
let's say put another version in the
repository then the cycle of uh
what of compiling your code and
deploying it pushing it to production
this will be done automatedly by just uh
creating a pipeline okay so that can be
done okay um and khan asks um
when you're talking about
a web app across regions can you have
the same web app running in multiple
regions or do you need to create
different versions
sorry sorry your voice was blinking can
you please come again
i'll just see otherwise
yeah it's khan's question about web apps
different regions
uh
actually i'm unable to see it basically
uh web apps you mentioned yeah and now i
can see it webex you mentioned earlier
about running in different region and
the traffic management we can deploy the
one web
so i was talking about traffic manager
okay so traffic manager is basically a
load balancing option in azure which can
actually balance the traffic across
different regions so whether you have
two vms in different regions that are
running your website so this traffic
manager can balance the load across
those two different vms or whether you
have two web apps that are running in
different regions so your uh traffic
manager again can can can put the
traffic on these two web apps that are
running in different regions so a
traffic manager is a is a global load
balancer that has the capability of of
of putting the traffic across different
regions uh across the web apps that are
in different regions so with a
particular app service plan in web app
that is p1v2 or s1 app service plan you
have the capability of using a traffic
manager okay with a normal like say your
basic app service plan um you may not
have that capability of using a traffic
manager with your web app correct i hope
that is good
okay
uh last couple of quick questions uh op
asks about
google cloud
and how that compares
google cloud okay uh whereas dcp this
has been great and has been directly no
no i'm not seeing that question just a
second what about gcp okay so see gcp is
another see if you'll ask me um these
three are the cloud platform but of
course gcp um
um
if you if you will compare the stats
with gartner right gartner is a research
organization so gcp is below aws and
azure okay you can ask it
to anybody right so it is it is it may
not be that matured as your aws and
azure is there and that's why you'll see
aws and azure being used more often than
gcp but of course it is you can say
third in the market okay so that is
again good and if you learn aws or azure
you can you can easily uh switch to gcp
also right so that is also there yeah
and then
over in the q and a um section that rpan
asks
if you can chain multiple rules for auto
scaling on using and or type of logic
if you can change what if you can chain
together multiple conditions
yes yes
yeah you can you can actually you can
create multiple matrix and based on that
you can actually uh do the scaling or
scale in or scale out i mean you can you
can increase the instances or decrease
the number of instances so you can
create multiple matrix also like as i
told you um
i i created just one matrix and i shown
you you can create another metric to
decrease the number of instances also so
likewise you can create multiple matrix
i mean based on multiple matrix you can
increase or decrease the number of
instances right
so
then then consing do we need to create
multiple instances on the same web app
in the same regions we want to run
multiple instances on the same web app
in the same region
see you can you can create
the multiple web apps in different
regions and then you can have your
traffic manager balance the load across
them or you can create the multiple web
apps in the same region also but you
do we need to create multiple instances
of the same web app in the regions we
want to run no you will you will be
creating the multiple instances of your
same web app in the same region it would
be created because when you have tried
to create your web app uh at that time
you specified the region of the web app
so that cannot be changed uh later on
right so all the instances of that web
app would be created in the same region
okay
i think that's uh that takes us to time
and um
i want to thank you i have a couple last
things to share with the audience
before we stood by so
let me pull this up um
you know we talked about
this
master class that we've done today um
we have different uh cloud computing
programs with simply learn and we
partner with
different organizations one of them is
caltech we have various programs in
cloud computing that are
comprehensive multiple months multiple
courses that take you from the basics
all the way up to
qualifying as a cloud engineer cloud
architect
a set of courses that will take from
aws fundamentals design through azure
fundamentals design and implementation
and up to a
capstone project that lets you
demonstrate all of the skills in the
real world type of application
so
these kinds of programs are available
through simplylearn
and
just a quick question
i'll run this
quick poll and see
who in the audience is interested in
this type of
program and i will also put into the
chat for you
the link to our
cloud computing programs page that will
let you look at
these and other cloud computing programs
that they offer
and
i'll close the poll in just a few
seconds
here but in the meantime
here is the link to our cloud computing
page with programs from simply learn
from caltech from
other partners
and
so about three quarters of the audience
are interested in
in this type of training i'll show you
the poll result here
and
so you can contact us to get started
we'll be sending a follow-up email with
the information but um
go to the cloud computing programs page
with diff programs
and you can contact us through those
pages
and with that
i will
thank
you tom very much for being here today
and be so generous with his time and
knowledge
thank you very much to it yeah thank you
guys thanks a lot for your time and
thanks to it i'm sorry i have taken your
additional time i hope no no no
as one of the the
attendees said
this is information that's relevant to
people's
work and they can apply it directly so
this is a
great session and i really appreciate
that and i've given uh in the chat your
linkedin link here that's displayed i've
also copied it to the chat so people can
contact you
um i'll just mention that we do have for
people who are in software development
uh very
interesting
um
i don't have to have the information
here but i'm gonna copy it in
into the chat we have a next
week on thursday
one week from today
a session with avital aurora who's the
vp of engineering at salesforce she's
going to be talking about
how to interview at an elite
company in the salesforce fang type
companies
so
take a look at that link that i just put
into the
chat for you
and if that's of interest to you uh
you're out there looking for
new employment or you want to move up
into an elite company that's a great
session because she'll
share with her
her experience
from having interviewed and hired a
multitude of engineers for salesforce
with that
just invite everybody to keep
in touch with us through our social
media channels
at
simplylearn on facebook at simplylearn
on twitter and
or simply learn on linkedin
and
thank you again to pershitam and to
everyone who has been here today
we hope you found value in it we hope we
can welcome you into the simply learn
learning community
yeah thank you all thanks a lot
participants for joining in here thanks
to it
thanks for calling me here thanks a lot
and yeah thank you bye
and that concludes our webinar for today
thanks so much
you